Haley fam is a lifestyle blogger who
shares a wide range of content to her
impressive 2.5 million subbies from
Fashion Halls to Beauty transformations
to book recommendations home decor
challenges tryons and a lot more there's
really something here for everyone and
for her 20-something fans she recently
launched her in my 20s Series where she
says goals starts new habits and finds
routines that feel good to her one of
which is learning how to cook and as
Foodies we love to see it so today we're
going to be putting Haley's cooking
skills to the test to take a look at
everything she cooks and of course eats
in a day hey everyone I'm Abby sharp
welcome to Abby's kitchen
foreign
[Music]
in today's video we'll be taking a look
at lifestyle vlogger Haley Pham and you
guys know the drill check out my
disclaimer down below I will be
mentioning a few macros and numbers here
so as always please feel free to skip
this video if that feels triggering to
you and if you're not already subscribed
help your girl out here hit that
subscribe button ring that Bell and
don't forget to follow me over on Tick
Tock and Instagram at Abby's kitchen
alright folks let's take a look so if
y'all have been following the in my 20
series on this channel where I'm trying
to get my life together you know that
one of my original goals was to teach
myself how to cook I really think that
learning to cook is a great example of a
non-diet behavior-based goal that you
can actually control that can and does
have positive impacts on our health
research suggests that food skills are
strongly associated with better diet
quality and also less food waste and of
course we know that it's a really great
way to save money as well we are
definitely coming into that new year new
you season and I ultimately would love
to see more resolutions like this so
let's take a look at an example of one
of her diabetes it's honestly so fast to
make them you just mix up egg whites I
get them from Trader Joe's toss in some
cinnamon some vanilla extract and then I
add a tiny bit of brown sugar girls I
feel like I can't really taste it if I'm
honest and then you just soak the bread
and toast it in the little fryer thingy
I think it's called protein French toast
because we're using egg whites okay we
love French toast in my house and
cooking it in egg whites well maybe not
as delicious does add a bit more protein
here so we're looking at around 15 grams
depending on the bread variety and we
know how important protein is at
breakfast for supporting energy levels
and appetite so if she wanted to bump
that up a little bit more I would serve
it maybe with some nice full fat Greek
yogurt or top it off with some nut
butter and hemp hearts which would also
help to make up for some of the lack of
fat that we would have had in the egg
jokes itself folks do not fear the fat
on another day she did a really
delicious looking avocado toast with egg
which in my books is a classic hunger
crushing combo and on day three she made
some really tasty looking airfryer
turkey sausages with an English muffin
with jelly now I do think breakfast is
always a really easy way to sneak in
some extra fiber rich produce so maybe
adding in a piece of extra fruit would
be a really great way to help build that
breakfast out I mixed this Trader Joe's
oat brown sugar creamer and the Delight
French vanilla creamer I use the verturo
I don't know how to say it but it's
basically a double shot of espresso
and mix it with a sugar cane straw it's
really not that much liquid but then I
make it iced and that's why I have today
because it's only a few glorious sips
love this statement right here I mean
you guys know the drill everyone's
coffee ritual is sacred to me so if
Haley likes a lot of creamer in her
coffee and it helps her save money at
the coffee shop then I'm here for it I'm
just gonna be so honest with you guys
it's now lunch time and usually for
lunch time I'm in the middle of the work
day and I need something Mega fast so
the Trader Joe's soup dumplings are so
good I like the chicken and the pork
ones and they literally take two minutes
in the microwave soy sauce in the middle
so I actually love that Haley isn't like
forcing herself to cook every single
meal from scratch here despite cooking
being kind of like her goal and kind of
like the theme of this video the vast
majority of us watching at home would
never be able to cook three meals from
scratch every single day
ain't nobody got time for that and I
really think that small manageable steps
will always be more likely to result in
long-lasting habits than like throwing
yourself into something too hard and too
fast all at once
[Music]
as for this meal I love frozen dumplings
and Trader Joe's let's be real Just Hits
different so we got a bit of carbs here
and some protein from The Filling I
would probably try to amp this up a bit
with some veggies for some extra fiber
and maybe a little bit more fat and
honestly it doesn't need to be fancy or
time consuming a pre-made salad kit with
some dressing or nuts would be great or
throwing a bag of pre-cut veggies into
the microwave and then like drizzling it
with some olive oil that'll be a really
great way to add in some healthy fats
plus some Fiber and potassium to
counterbalance the sodium in the frozen
dumplings ditto with her post-workout
lunch another day where she had like a
really simple protein shake with some
banana almond milk and protein powder I
would say that's a pretty light lunch
for most people so for the general
population I'd recommend maybe adding in
a little more fiber and fat in that meal
so like throwing in some frozen spinach
and some extra berries and a lot of
peanut butter or some hemp Parts as well
a meal smoothie really does need to have
those fiber rich carbs protein and
healthy fats you guys have been telling
me to try hellofresh for so long it's
not sponsored
so I think meal kits are really great if
you're like just learning how to cook or
if you're a seasoned cook but you're
maybe in a bit of a rut and you need
some new recipe inspiration and let's be
real you can never go wrong with a
homemade burger
love that we got some carbs and a bit of
fiber in the potatoes and some protein
and fat in the burger but again I would
probably love to see a little more
veggie action in here so if she were to
throw together like a quick bagged salad
kit for lunch she could also add some on
the side right here as well I also loved
the crispy Teriyaki tofu recipe that she
made right here and I think that we all
can relate to this I usually make
broccoli as well but I got really
overwhelmed this day because I was
making it for three people and I burned
the teriyaki sauce raise your hand if
you've ever burnt one thing while trying
to babysit another
too many times to count honestly but
like most skills cooking takes a lot of
practice this especially when it comes
to like timing and multitasking so of
course making little mistakes like this
is to be expected as part of the journey
I can't even count the times that I have
royally messed up a recipe or like
things didn't go as planned and I had to
just like do my best to salvage it or
completely start over or of course just
like smothered it in barbecue sauce and
tried to like hide the evidence yeah we
go through a lot of barbecue sauce in my
house so we have just applied the Sweet
Baby Ray's sweet baby rays as for
Haley's meal I love that we're getting
some plant-based protein with the tofu
and some carbs from the minute rice and
I think it's actually great practice to
set a goal of making one meal component
for dinner and then just like
shortcutting the rest I mean I'm an
award-winning cookbook author and even I
do this every day if it were me just to
like streamline the process a bit more
and not have to think about multiple
components cooking all at once I would
simply throw some frozen vegetables in
with the minute rice and call it
something like minute stir fry but
anyways let's take a look at dessert I'm
having a diet Dr Pepper cream soda these
things are so addicting and a pumpkin
chocolate chip cookie okay so not to go
all mom on Haley but like I am so proud
of her for this earlier on in this video
she tried to make this pumpkin cookie
recipe for her Bible study group and
yeah like it didn't work out as planned
so I love that she gave it another go to
perfect this recipe that is just like
such an admirable trait cooking was
always one of those things I just told
myself I would never be good at and I
would never be interested in it and now
I actually get really excited to make
new meals bake new recipes and I just
think it's really fun that I'm still
discovering new things that I previously
thought I would never be able to
accomplish and it is one of the most
rewarding feelings this totally warms my
heart and honestly the narratives that
we tell ourselves about what we can and
can't do are powerful as [ __ ] research
suggests that using positive
affirmations can activate parts of the
brain that are associated with
self-related processing and reward so
basically these affirmations can become
hardwired into our brain as fact so for
example if you're constantly telling
yourself that you will never be good at
cooking this can become a
self-fulfilling prophecy but if you tell
yourself that you'll be good at this
skill you are much more likely to take
action towards it and succeed and we
love to see it honestly I feel like this
video came at a really important time as
a lot of us are planning our New Year's
resolutions and unlike goals like I want
to lose five pounds or I want to be a
size four learning to cook is an
actionable smart goal that we do have
more control over and it just so happens
to be a goal that can have multiple
other bonus benefits as well I also just
love the accessibility of the meals that
are featured in this week I mean there
were some civil meals made from scratch
some meal kits microwave options and a
combination of all of the above and most
importantly I just really love that
Haley was not afraid to mess up like
dust herself off and start again without
breaking a sweat most of the time I feel
like social media food content is such
an unrealistic highlight reel where
everything has to be styled beautifully
and perfectly for the gram so on that
note that is all that I have for you
guys today if you like this video be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below on who or what you'd like
to see me review next subscribe to this
Channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
foreign
[Music]